Kobe Bryant was of course a basketball
legend but also a businessman and author
and a husband and father
Bryant would routinely skip going to
Lakers games after his retirement to
attend his daughter's games CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson
spoke with him about his family last
fall she's outside the Staples Center in
Los Angeles which has Alicia Keys has
said last night is really of course the
house that Kobe Bryant built
Dana what's happening there Anthony as
you can see we've got this makeshift
memorial Gail mentioned the keepsakes
that are there from the fans paying
tribute to Kobe Bryant and his family
athletes also remembering Kobe so many
of them point to the father that he had
become Derek Jeter and online posting
wrote that despite Kobe's athletic gifts
and his obsession to win he always put
family above everything and that was
something that when we spoke back in
October was quite a parent are you
enjoying being able to have time with
them oh I am Kobe was the man of the
house he shared with wife Vanessa and
their four daughters you're the only man
what does the Bryant household like I'm
very comfortable with where I met on the
totem pole
Kobe told me he was enjoying more time
with daughters Natalya Gianna Bianca and
newborn Capri his main job since
retiring in 2016
dad in your house do they look at you
and go dad's just stop be quiet you know
oh my god yeah like I never know what
I'm talking about I have absolutely no
say-so and they do a tongue-in-cheek but
they mean it except maybe when it came
to basketball Kobe's 13 year old
daughter Gigi had developed her own love
of the game you coached Gigi's
basketball team yeah what's the biggest
challenge in coaching your own daughter
making sure she knows that I love her
whether she plays well or plays like
crap no matter it's fine you know you're
my daughter before you're a basketball
player is there a different sense of
pride in watching her out
as her coach being there what I love the
most is that we've gotten to a place now
where she sees something that's making
her uncomfortable on the court she'll
come up and say hey Dad
this is what's happening this is what
I'm feeling what should I do here
coby's so proud to be the father to
those four daughters but if you think
about it who really was a father to so
many others I said it earlier but he
inspired a generation of athletes and
that included those girls on Gianna's
team the girls left behind
obviously today Tony are dealing with
more loss than any of us can even
imagine Wendy and we loved what he had
to say in your interview that that she's
his daughter first a basketball player
only second Dana thank you very much